and his mother lived alone in a small
house on a hill how's it going brahs
Isaac kept to himself my name is Peter
Hanson playing well I just do the body
nice and watch Christian you guys gotta
watch this I am gonna keep quiet
actually life was simple and they were
both happy
that was until the day Isaac's mom heard
a voice from above I deflower on has
become corrupted by sin he needs to be
saved I will do my best to save him my
lord Isaac's mother replied rushing into
Isaac's room removing all that was this
is the safe like I and this I don't
wanna travel is it so Arthur Isaac's
soul is still corrupt he needs to be cut
off from all that is evil in this world
and confess his sins I will follow your
instructions
I love Petra expended all Isaac this is
Saint created as Super Meat Boy jr. away
from Isaac is more awesome than super
meat boy I think in these one last time
Isaac's mom heard the voice of God
calling to her you've done as I've asked
but I still question your devotion to me
to prove your faith I will ask one more
thing of you
yes Lord anything Isaac's mother begged
fell over to improve your love and
devotion I require a sacrifice your son
Isaac will be this sacrifice known an
attic Nair and his life as an offering
to me to prove you love me above all
else yes Lord
she replied grabbing our snuff now Isaac
were I they were crack in his door
here it's rambling around as men lived
at a hiding place he noticed a trap door
to the basement yeah under his rug
without hesitation he flung open the
hatch without just as his mother burst
through his door and threw himself down
into the unknown depths below all right
there we are
it's beautiful
all right so there we go welcome through
the binding of issac let's go I guess
we're gonna pick us Isaac I have played
this a little bit it is a lot of fun I
can laugh gonna lie I don't know why I
would lie about that but I just need to
change controls really quick okay there
we go it's randomly generated each map
so every time you played it's a
different experience and you're
basically Isaac all crying your stuff
and shooting tears because we all know
tears are really lethal and come on
Isaac you can do it
these are pretty much in one I hate
balls I don't even know I don't know why
I kind of called a jumping pajamas or
something
so you go out it's really difficult if
you guys are familiar with Super Meat
Boy then you know that it's gonna be a
difficult game if there's the same
developer
and you can pick up all these kind of
hydrants or stuff I don't know what I
just did
wow that was bad that's not good that's
bad if Emma
all right this way Isaac I know you're
sad and stuff but do we need to go wow I
get the weirdest I never seen this
before and I played for a long time I
get the weirdest Rickon
thanks okay good I need help and if you
die everything restart us so I don't
want to [ __ ] up I'm gonna play it until
I die this first video I don't care if
it's 15 minutes okay I care actually I'm
kind of stopped it's all right it's got
me go I said great oh one more of them
that can scrub this early it's difficult
at these games never got come on make it
cry your teeth why is it keep missing
holy [ __ ] perfect let's try this again
okay just one more time all right
hi I died on purpose hey you see it's
different now from the first time I play
like oh look she had a chest oh yeah I'm
ray Wow I worried
I hate those friggin flies hate the
Flies
those flies are okay but the sigh hey
nope
good for now I
and we pick up a bump
I know love the music music
it's beautiful
huh nothing
let's go ahead what do we got defconn
cars facies all right let's get we need
that and there's a boss fight in each
stage or whatever you want to call it
billiard balls of steel
so the first boss is is like versus
Larry I think bombs are good ideas yep
that bombs are definitely good ah come
on I think funny when they drop buoys
yes
and the food turns into a smiley face by
the way
ah come on Isaac shape up okay go
that could've gone better
I just have to do it my way alright go
go go go go go that was beautiful and
there we go so we got the first stage
flared out yes
[ __ ] yes and we got a milk box it's
breakfast that's what I call it so I
just love everything what is he doing
people are moving into class and inside
about it
for Isaac all right wake time to wake up
I wake up and smell the ashes okay let's
break it up oh I got this freaking then
what don't you dare
now come on
all right this way time to go through
everything
our days of crash
ah these I hate face suck out that much
come on Isaac up
okay we're getting
I know
okay
here different
there it is huh take over that Isaac why
are you so sad I tell me all Wow
they don't look bad if I was he oh wait
nevermind shoot your tears Isaac do it
yes huh I was just a lot of martyr he's
beautiful
oh I should blood Wow look at that
that's gotta be good
I hope I can make it through the first
by probably actually okay I got it feels
here yeah
full house wait ah they look really nice
but then they turn into this yeah no
problem
no okay let's go left
it's why the [ __ ] nut okay
I actually survived holy [ __ ]
and we got I don't even know what these
do okay not that's what they do
oh but we need to fight the bus its
flies oh it's not a boss assistant I
don't even know something hi these are
the worst there's no way I can make it
holy [ __ ] he's going after the rock I
can pick up bars okay
the blood this thing is awesome is so
much that I told [ __ ] okay
all right and I got an audition sweet
and then print that comment good all
right let's go for the boss fight just
because Isaac versus gemiini Scott them
sex his knee okay I got this I got that
is that problem Isaac got man huh God
wash up for that kinda liver that's what
she said okay
ah come on I need a better tiger
our cue uh-oh
okay I got it space my later
how's that fam why did I use that sooner
all right whatever let's go that's girl
okay stage three
you can do it ah poor Isaac it's a bad
friend oh god I hate these okay we're
good
we're nowadays coming here little [ __ ]
it looks so cute but they are horrible
okay can even fall down in those I don't
think you can't ha
okay we got this
go up you [ __ ]
oh Jesus
yeah I'll push it down the hole that
stubborn little [ __ ] come here
now your cans really
piggies bike no not back really kiss
already do boss fight should be high why
not Isaac viruses fistula is that Allah
good what the heck is that
I don't even know this is killing oh
[ __ ] whoa
rickety cry
I thought I could use pickax who's that
this is our about how this sub oh come
on I don't want to die now come on Isaac
got a heck out of here
oh it's almost then wait wait did I do
it
Riley I need that hard really do that
hard okay thank bud everywhere
I'm doing pretty well actually not holy
[ __ ] what's this the belt ah I liquid
badass I'm looking like the caves too
I heard when he fell down for Isaac
is this no I'm not going to give you my
money
oh look pretty start with this little
buckaroo
I like crying I don't even care
- easy for feedback I'm here to fall
okay
look at highs I get so cool
I hate
come here time to go good
okay let's go ahead
up-up
Susan's other stuff everywhere are you
kidding me stop following me
did I really kill that one [ __ ] ah
nah okay we're good
what is this details here bad trip oh I
have one health now that's not good and
I knew dear diary today I was killed I
was killed by this thing and gave in
some cake I leave all the zone to my cat
group copy that's a lot of cool stuff
goodbye cruel world
xoxo Isaac alright that's it for today
I'll try this again tomorrow if you guys
want to like and favorite and subscribe
oh really
[ __ ] uh oh my [ __ ] foot ah ah
seriously [ __ ] heart